[Music]
as Las Vegas copes with the trauma of
the coronavirus the trauma of another
major event still lingers here it's been
more than two years since the 1 October
shooting and even now the wounds are not
healing this afternoon family members of
one shooting survivors say she is
gravely ill suffering complications from
the attack Hector Mejia spoke with the
family of Samantha our June he is live
now the downtown healing garden Hector
you have profiled Samantha before I have
John and we got to know Samantha you
know a little bit in this afternoon as
you can imagine her family at a loss for
words the healing garden here has become
a place to honor remember all of the
victims and survivors one of them this
afternoon
Samantha June is at the hospital here in
the valley fighting for her life and
Samantha June has endured a lot of pain
since the tragic night of 1 October 2017
a gunshot wound shattered bones in her
left leg that night in 2018 the our June
family welcome channel 8 into their home
as we profiled Samantha's recovery this
morning her father told me the 48 year
old is hospitalized with the help of a
respirator Samantha had been on a
journey to find the angels who saved her
life that that night at the concert
strangers carried her put her in a car
and drove her to a hospital and in
conversation Samantha shared with me
that she refused to be a victim for the
rest of her life she said that instead
she would focus on her healing the Aaron
family wants the 1 October community to
know that she did not have access to her
phone for some time so they want them to
know that she's facing another painful
battle our most sincere thoughts go out
to the entire arjen family this
afternoon reporting from the healing
garden Hector Mejia 8 news now it's very
heartbreaking Hector thank you very much
for the story though